the survival drama squid game has got a
grip on netflix users and a majority of
the internet for that matter those who
decided to watch the series thinking
they were in for anything remotely
lighthearted found themselves in for a
gruesome surprise as the show is
anything but that squid game follows a
character named sangion who decides to
join a mysterious competition to win
money and attempt to pay off his
gambling debts not long into the first
game kihan learns that it's going to be
much more intense than he thought and
this time he's betting with his life one
of the first allies gehan makes in squid
game is an elderly man known at first as
just player one yun is understandably
shocked to see such a frail looking man
taking part in the competition and we
soon learned that player 1 has a
terminal illness exacerbated by a brain
tumor and he decided to join the games
rather than die of his illness the
biggest twist in the entire first season
of squid game occurs in the very last
episode when kian realizes that player 1
aka ol nam is still alive a shock after
he was seemingly eliminated after the
marble game as it turns out player one
was one of the obscenely wealthy
masterminds behind the entire
competition and his execution after the
marble game was faked player one and the
rest of the cartel are the same puppet
masters who decided to create the games
as a source of entertainment
oh this is exciting
gentlemen
this may be the deciding moment
despite his deception about his
involvement in the games player one's
reasons for joining remain pretty
consistent throughout the show as he
originally tells his fellow competitors
he joined the competition for excitement
since his terminal illness which is real
means he doesn't have long to live he
wanted to experience the adrenaline rush
of competing in the life or death games
even if he knew he had a major advantage
over the other players not only that but
he wanted to experience the game as a
player because he'd been observing the
twisted festivities for years as a vip
with all the time he spent watching from
behind the scenes he surely knew a few
secrets no other player could know which
ensured that he could maximize his time
in the competition and get the most fun
out of it as he could it wasn't too hard
to decipher player one's true intentions
for eagle-eyed viewers when the games
began while many contestants show fear
and anxiety during the opening moments
of red light green light player one
charges ahead with a gleeful expression
on his face when you first watch the
episode he just seems like a crazy and
fearless old man ready to die when he's
actually a crazy and fearless old man
ready to die who also knows very well
how to play these games from his
childhood since he's behind them all and
has likely seen them play out several
times over the years
that said his strategy during tug of war
while solid and ultimately very helpful
wasn't foolproof he really could have
died during that game which is evidence
that he was in it for the thrill and
nostalgia factor and was willing to die
if he had to since the growing tumor in
his brain is like a ticking time bomb in
the season finale he reveals to gihan
from his deathbed that his extreme
wealth made him bored with life and that
he and the other rich vips put the games
together so they could finally have some
fun as to why he joined the games
himself knowing he could die he told
gehan this from the english dub in my
childhood i always had so much fun out
doing things with all of my friends we'd
lose track of time for hours i wanted to
just feel something just one last time
before i die and you are not going to
get that feeling if you are just going
to spectate and i desperately wanted
that he goes on to tell gihan that he
did indeed experience the fun he was
after thanks to gihan then he dies
before he can offer any more explanation
this huge twist makes squid game an
excellent candidate for re-watch despite
its brutality as all of player one's
decisions take on a whole new meaning
the second time around check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]